welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Millicent Marcus a professor of
Italian at Yale she specializes in
Italian culture from the
interdisciplinary perspectives of
literature history and film she is the
author of several books on italian film
as well as many journal articles today
we'll talk with professor Marcus about
her research on the anti-mafia martyr
genre in Italian film welcome professor
Marcus thank you so much for having me
what an interesting topic let's begin
you know with an overview of the genre
tell us about it okay well it done it
really begins in the early 1980s which
is the time of the most intensive mafia
war against this state and it includes
about 11 films that's by my count there
may be more and they they include mainly
with only one exception actually
biographical portraits of anti-mafia
activists who died in in their struggle
against the Mafia and the the range of
people included in this is very
important because we have three of the
films are about judges obviously then
there's one about a labor organizer one
about a chief of the cabin yeti that's
the Italian police one about a
journalist one about a cultural
organizer one about a priest and one
about a mafia daughter who turns state's
evidence so this is sort of the range
that we're getting very diverse yeah
yeah very good okay and this is in Italy
specifically in Sicily or are there any
other parts of Italy good question this
is insist Lee and really mainly Palermo
not completely also Corleone a which is
a name that the audience might recognize
and there's one of the figures is
actually
from Naples and therefore a victim of
the Kimura which is the Neapolitan mafia
okay and these films they're not
documentaries they're actually dramas
somewhat based on reality exactly I
think that's a very important point that
these are historical figures and their
stories might be a little bit Romans
otha as we say in Italian or
romanticized or novelized I think that's
that yep but they're all based on
historical fact and that's very
important okay and what led you to be
interested in this well in the year 2000
2001 I noticed that too very brilliant
films came out the very same year on
anti-mafia martyrs one called the 100
steps that I want to talk more about in
depth in a minute about pepino impastato
a cultural organizer and the other
clergy dodi thought thought about a
labor organizer who was killed in the
late 1940s and I saw out the convergence
of these two films in 2000-2001 I
thought mm-hmm something's going on here
and then in looking more closely at it I
realized there had been several films
preceding it within this genre and then
since then a whole series of films
following it and this is a genre that
I've just sort of myself identified I
don't know if other film scholars agree
with me and the label is is mine but I
think it's very valid and very
legitimate in terms of defining this
particular body of work and how do you
find the film's I mean you are a
professor of Italian so I imagine you
are interested in Italy so are these
films primarily released in italy or can
you also find them here in the united
states alas many of them are not
accessible to American audiences which
is really a pity some of them are the
100 steps for example that I'll talk
about but most of them are not most of
them are not even translated you know
they don't have English subtitles there
in PAL which is the European format so
they can't even be sure
on DVDs here and some part of my mission
I feel is to introduce the American and
english-speaking audiences to this very
important body of work because so often
the Mafia you know the the media are so
obsessed with with the Mafia yeah itself
and have fueled this kind of obsession
and sensationalized the phenomenon but
these films show very the other side
that I am an decide that I don't think
many people know exist exactly here in
this country exactly interesting all
right so let's talk about 100 steps okay
so this is the film of his name is Pepe
no impastato and this young man lived in
China Sea which is right outside of
Palermo right where the airport of
Palermo is located his father was had
been patronized by the Mafia the Mafia
that sort of bought him a pizza dia so
so the the family of pepino was really
indebted to the Mafia their uncle who
lived right down the street was a big
boss's name was gaetano badalamenti and
the title of the film 100 steps refers
to the fact that the epi nose family
lived literally 100 steps down the
street okay from this mafia boss so the
point of the film is that the Mafia is
so sort of integrated into everyone's
life that you simply cannot escape it
but the pianos point was to resist it
and so he started a kind of youth
movement and he did it through a the
medium of radio because in the 1970s
there was a movement called Garagiola
Barack where anybody could just set up
you know an antenna
whatever equipment and begin to
broadcast he did and he played rock and
roll music and they talked about the
sexual revolution but his main point was
to her to kill the Mafia well you don't
ridicule the Mafia in public if you know
what's good for you it sounds dangerous
didn't stop him and he proceeded on this
path and ultimately became very
political he was a member of the
Communist Party but he felt that the
Communists were to an effectual and then
he became a candidate for the Democrats
iam Paulette Gaudio which was further to
the left and during that campaign he was
assassinated by the Mafia by tomorrow
okay I am wondering since the Mafia
basically bought the pizzeria for his
family what turned him against the Mafia
what a great question his own sense of
what was right and what was wrong he was
he was just a rebel from birth and he
was also very very educated his father
his parents were not they were very
simple and so through education through
humanist culture he got certain values
about what the civil order should be and
what it shouldn't be and this empowered
him and he became a very charismatic
leader when he died his funeral turned
into a protest movement and a call to
arms and we get the beginning of a
grassroots movement which still today
has an office called the chainsaw pepino
impastato dedicated to him in his memory
okay I am wondering how how well
received these films are well that film
was very acclaimed both by critics and
by the general audience and became and
the filmmaker it became a launching pad
for the filmmakers careers name was
coolio Jordanna Michael to Joe Jordanna
and the main actor Ouija LoCascio who
Pitino has gone on to great stardom as a
result so that film did really really
well other films have been less noticed
less well distributed except for the
film that I'm going to tell you about
okay tell us about it okay ready yeah so
the film that I'm working on now in my
research and that fascinates me is part
of the genre and not part of the genre
it's part of it in that the director's
name is a pier francesco diliberto was
the assistant director to Jordanna for
the 100 steps but he went on to become a
big TV celebrity among it's sort of a
young demographic and on TV shows like
the equivalent of candid camera where he
plays a really goofy kind of guy and
then later his own television show
called it testimony which means the
witness and that was on MTV so you can
imagine again the kind of public really
attracted and in that TV show he did a
series of interviews and really created
a very powerful public persona the huge
following but as a guy who was kind of
funny and zany etc and then he decided
to make his first film and his first
film is called the Mafia only kills in
the summer ok it is a romantic comedy
heavily autobiographical because
diliberto himself grew up in Palermo
during the years of this most intense
mafia war at this date and so he
embodies himself in this little boy
named Arturo by the way Arturo is
conceived on the same night that there
is a mafia attack on the apartment
building where his parents are
conceiving him okay and to be graphic
there's an egg and a flotilla of sperm
and those sperm are turned away because
the attack on the building's causes the
building to shake uh-huh but one little
sperm lags behind
and didn't know what was going on and
he's this firm who pierces the end and
thus begins to life a little odd through
it all and I'm not easy as a result of
this as a small child he is very
sensitive to the Mafia presence in his
midst as a kind of paranormal
sensitivity he's very slow to begin
talking and his parents are trying to
get him to extract at least a mama from
him but the first word he utters is when
a priest comes to visit their house who
happened to have mafia ties and so you
can guess what his first word was mafia
yeah I guess I know you got it so this
young boy though it's a told you it's a
romantic comedy he falls in love with a
young girl named Florida and he's
courting her this little kid is courting
her but every time he tries to impress
her or woo her something happens in the
public sphere to thwart his his romantic
hopes and what happens in the public
sphere is a mafia assassination to give
you an example so he writes on the
pavement in front of her apartment house
with chalk he writes this impassioned
love love note to her it just so
happened she never gets to see it
because a mafia anti-mafia judge living
in the apartment is assassinated right
there things like this are happening
uh-huh you collect the coincidence quite
the coincidence and all these
coincidences happen when he grows up
he's finally able to win her over and
they marry and they have a little boy
and the end of the film so that most of
the film has been light and fluffy and
playful with these interventions of
mafia history but at the very end
there's this beautiful beautiful
conclusion and this is what links the
film to the anti-mafia martyrs rumor is
that our total takes his little boy and
takes him to visit all of the plaques
throughout palermo dedicated to the
martyr
of the various figures we've seen
throughout the film before and more and
this little boy and you see various cuts
of the visits to the plaques and the
little boy get is a little older and a
little older but you can never really
understand and yet what you see is that
our turtle is bent on transmitting this
legacy to the new generation and it
becomes very very very serious at the
end and it becomes a series of memorials
to the martyrs of the cause right so
this film sounds very different than the
other ones in terms of it is light
nomming up until the end the Mafia is
very much alive still insist yes do you
think that these films you know will
have any bearing on people's outlook on
the Mafia well that's a great question
and I have a two-part answer to it your
point that the Mafia is very much alive
comes out in one of deliberate dos
episodes of testimony where he
interviews a bunch of young people
who've decided to band together against
the fact that the Mafia requires that
merchants shopkeepers pay a tribute
protection money and if they don't
they're in trouble and this protection
money in the slang of Palermo pizza pizo
not to be mistaken for pizza and this
group has bonded together in a movement
called a do pizza or goodbye to this
tribute so it's very much alive and well
the second point that you made are these
the question are these films able to
change the way people think and this I
want to take back tuna to the entire
Italian film tradition starting with the
post-war movement of neo-realism which
some of your viewers might have seen
films like Rome open city with an
ammonia
knee or bicycle thief these films were
the outgrowth of the resistance movement
during World War two and these film the
resistance movement itself after the
shame of fascism and the devastation of
the war this movement wanted to wanted
Italy to be reborn a rebirth of social
justice and the neo-realist movement
grows out of this and the idea is that
these films will be an intervention in
the life of the country that it will
point out social injustice and that it
will instill the desire in audiences to
do something about I to act the
anti-mafia martyr film is part of this
tradition and I feel very strongly that
that this genre is really about really
is a call to arms the 100 steps and I
told you with the funeral of Peppino and
it becomes a protest rally and it's a
challenge to the audience especially in
this new millennium when the young
people don't have that kind of
revolutionary fervor that we saw for
example in the 1970s even in the 1990s
when we see this grassroots movement
coming up that those grass roots the
grass is withered so these filmmakers
are appealing to the public and saying
we have to act and it's one critic wrote
the film shows that it is still possible
to rebel fascinating thank you so much
for being here today and sharing some of
your work there's been my pleasure thank
you so much for having me for more
information about professor Marcus and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale